hey guys what's up new flash episode
it's finally back so let's break it down
episode 10 just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet they're doing so
much hardcore flash family stuff so as I
do new videos I'll talk more and more
about the rest of the flash family about
the other speedsters but there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of my
episode videos so many comic book Easter
eggs so let's do top 12 instead of
normal top 10 so number 12 Barry's been
having nightmares and he's been living
with iris for the past month so they
have this apartment together
you'd think they'd be having a whole lot
of fun but Barry hasn't told anyone has
been keeping this inside an iris reminds
him that Wally is helping him out when
he gets the call for the fire so number
11 is Wally West learning on the job so
he doesn't know like Barry to canvas the
situation it's the exact same lesson
that Oliver taught Barry way back during
the season 1 crossover where he's like
you are a speedster you have the time to
canvass the room before you rush in and
do something so this is really going to
bite Wally in the ass down the road so
number 10 okay Wally West is headed for
a big ass-whooping he is going to get
his ass handed to him because he's so
over eager but you can see why he just
become a speedster so it's very
understandable and he gets the Greg
Grunberg dish so awesome Easter Egg that
he shows up again he actually appeared
during the Kevin Smith episode in the
first half of the season so it's always
fun to see him on the show but he's a
total [ __ ] just talking down Wally
Wally hears it maybe he's not as fast as
the normal flash and he drops a big
comic book Easter Egg number 9 maybe we
should send him to Keystone City we
already have a flash way back during the
Wally West air in the comics the ginger
Wally West
he lived in Keystone City so all the
stories all the villains it was all
localized in that city but when you look
at the map it's actually right here on
the other side of the river from Central
City so Barry Allen's era in the comics
was in Central City Wally West's was in
Keystone City but keep in mind that TV
show Wally West is sort of an amal
of the original ginger Wally West in the
new 52 Wally West if you've been reading
the rebirth comic lately they've changed
the african-american Wally West again
now he's irises nephew he's even younger
and he's part of the Teen Titans just
learning from Barry on who's much much
older
so TV show Wally West is sort of like a
combination of all the versions of Wally
West but number 8 Kaylin invites
Julianne to join team flash so dr.
alchemy eventually coming to the team it
takes a little while in the episode it's
all part of Barry's art when he finally
chills out tells the team keeping
secrets from the team is never good so
dr. alchemy was never part of team flash
in the comics or anything like that but
they're doing this thing where they're
sort of like flipping the alignment of
some villains and heroes just playing
around with it a little bit so the
reformed dr. alchemy in the comics is
actually a good person so you can
actually say it's pretty true to the
comics but the twist with dr. alchemy in
the comics was a little bit different it
was a legit split personality the evil
dr. alchemy persona was the bad person
so you could say the TV show version is
just a good aspect of his personality
but there'll be a lot of fun they've
been filming the gorilla city episodes
from behind the scenes so you see them
hanging out together on set in the funny
thing here is this is tom Felton in real
life well grant gustin's real life first
name is actually Tom he just goes by
Grant instead of Tom Gustin so you have
two toms hanging out on set here
real-life Easter Egg
but next big thing number seven
Caitlin's wristband is Fritzing out and
she slowly turns into killer frost for a
sec before she gets the battery plugged
in so the big thing here is that she is
on a ticking clock they're trying to
change the future but they want to let
you know that she is turning into killer
frost very quickly so the wristband is
very very important like that battery
was only dead for like five seconds and
her eyes slipped out so you could
imagine that if she took it off for an
hour or two she might go full-blown
killer frost number six berry has that
first confrontation with plunder sets
off the a story which is him versus
wall-e trying to avoid this future
timeline so everything is crazy and it
takes him a while before he finally
starts to come
clean and eventually thank God they're
finally cool by the end of the episode
because berry vs. wall-e is one of the
worst things that this show could do big
surprise though HR steel Cisco's Thunder
naming him plunder for being such a
pirate so number five
Barry versus Wally so this is all about
Wally thinking about Greg Grunberg
insulting him for not being fast enough
not doing his job
so he wants to rush in and help he's not
thinking about stealing Barry's thunder
or anything like that but he starts to
step into the limelight and then Barry
later picks up on that and they use that
as a way to change the future so it
becomes a good thing later on but for
like the middle part of the episode it
almost seemed like there's going to be
some sort of conflict between them so
I'm so glad that they cut that off at
the past like you do not want team flash
fighting with each other especially
flash family now they all think of each
other's family but when you talk about
flash family you're just talking about
the speedsters so you have like that
funny moment where he sticks his suit in
Barry's spot that's meant to be more
awkward like it could have been a lot
worse if they were still fighting each
other at the end of the episode but
thankfully they're all good so Wally
will chill a little bit but like I said
he's still headed for a big ass-whipping
because he does not think the way that
Barry does but it's a very well to get
there number four Wally takes down
plunder in pursuit of changing the
future gets that big crowd shot
everyone's cheering for him it's great
you know great way to end the episode
they had that real awesome chase scene
with plunder with all the crazy bullets
Cisco got the gun he's going to upgrade
that so we'll probably see it later this
season somebody will get to use it and
if you felt like the museum that they
tracked plunder down to look familiar
that's because it looks exactly like the
outside of the flash museum that Barry
saw when he time-traveled in the first
season that's still a long ways off like
we have to do a lot of flash family
stuff before we get to flash museum but
they said way back during season one
that when we got those visions they were
going to do all those things
number three Barry comes clean to Iris
in the Time Vault and explains that in
four months she is going to die unless
they find a way to change the future so
normally she's the one that calms him
down but
now she's freaking out a little bit he
finally tells the rest of the team but
the ticking clock is four months so what
that means is it's basically season
finale so see what they did there iris
is going to die in the season finale of
season 3 unless they change the future
curves a domino example where they find
the right events to change so that's
where we get into the headline in iris
pointed out a really important point if
you threw the philosopher's stone into
the speedforce
then how does avatar get out so that's
another thing that they tease is going
to happen in the future and it'll
probably have something to do with Barry
and team flash trying to take steps to
avoid that future fate they will do
something that will inevitably lead to
that outcome number two it says music
Meister six-figure book deals the music
Meister episode is going to be the
musical crossover he's being played by
Darren Criss so it's going to be like a
Glee reunion so be a couple of them that
will sing in the episode but I'll do
like a separate video about the musical
crossover but it just implies that music
Meister comes out of that looking really
good killer frost still at large so
Caitlin's freaking out about that
STAR Labs museum closes which is bad
news for HR city recovers from gorilla
attack which is a teaser for the
two-part Gorilla Grodd episode that
might be episodes 13 and 14 but they're
filming those right now it's going to be
huge it is going to be so awesome
and then Captain Joe West gets honored
so joe becomes captain somehow all these
other things are happening they're going
to try and change them one at a time
number one though is the big surprise at
the end after the party where gypsy from
Earth 19 come through a wormhole
tracking down HR so they've already
explained like the reason for this gypsy
has vibe powers just like Cisco but
she's way more hardcore has much more
command of her abilities much more
experience so next week's episode is
going to be all about by versus gypsy
but you can kind of see like she looks
really hot so he's going to totally be
obsessed with her she'll be a villain
when they meet but it sounds like
they'll have a similar relationship as
cisco had with golden glider where she
wasn't totally bad they were a little
ambiguous about it they'll probably
some alternative way of stopping her but
you have to keep in mind that HR is sort
of the replacement at STAR Labs for
earth to Harrison wells
in the gorilla City episode is supposed
to be earth to so whatever's going to
happen with the future of HR on the show
we'll probably find out next week but
the other big easter egg it was like one
more big killer frost easter egg from
the party where they're all giving each
other gifts they give Caitlyn the
solar-powered battery on that pendant
but it looks exactly like the one Louise
Lincoln wears on her killer frost
costume so she is the Caitlin snow
killer frost Louise Lincoln is a
slightly different version of the
character but you see it on her future
costume that Cisco saw when he vibed her
in the first half of the season so this
is all implying that we're still going
to get a form of killer frost in the
future but just like they're doing in
the comics they might make her a good
version of the character because Caitlin
snow in the comics right now is part of
the Justice League so they might do that
version of killer frost on the TV show
but let me know what was your guy's
favorite moment it was a great episode
cannot wait to meet gypsy next week it's
going to be awesome
so I'll say congratulations to the new
injustice giveaway winner reverse
jurado's just private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round of
the giveaway that started in this video
I'll just announce the winner in my
flash trailer video that'll post next
then I'll post legends of tomorrow so
just a reminder legends of tomorrow is
on Tuesdays now so we'll just remind
everyone with the video schedule is as I
post new videos while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about the Flash's greatest power and
you can click here to learn all about
episode 8 the last Jenna thank you so
much for watching everybody so I thought
I'll see you guys tonight